think that the care homes have been of
course what happened in care homes
uh was was was tragic and we but we did
everything we could to
protect the nhs to minimize transmission
with the knowledge that we had one thing
that we
we did not know at the beginning of the
pandemic and don't forget this
we did not know the beginning of the
pandemic quite
the way in which the virus could be
transmitted asymptomatically and that
was one of the reasons
that we had some of the problems that we
uh we saw in
in cairns but what we're doing now is
what we're doing now the right person
what we're doing now is what we're doing
now
is is trying obviously to protect all
residents in
in all care homes uh they have a i think
they've all had
uh vaccines up to you know 99 if not 100
and that's the that's the crucial thing
well let's remind you again of some of
the most explosive claims made by
dominic cummings during more than seven
hours of evidence he said the health
secretary matt hancock lied
and should have been fired 20 times over
including for criminal
disgraceful behavior relating to his
target for one hundred thousand tests a
day
well as you've been hearing he said it
was complete nonsense when the
government claimed that a protective
shield was put around
care homes and said that he personally
heard the widely reported comments by
the prime minister that he would rather
let the bodies pile
high than have a third lockdown and he
suggested that the list of mistakes made
meant tens of thousands of people died
who didn't need to die well our
political editor beth
rigby joins me now um beth in terms of
what we've heard
from matt hancock this morning has he
answered those questions those
allegations that dominic cummings made
yesterday
well i think jane the first thing to say
was he was very robust in saying that he
wasn't
a liar that he had been straight with
people that was his message
uh in the commons but i think it's true
to say as well
that when he was asked by a series of
mps of detailed
questions surrounding mr commons
allegations you remember
one of the main ones was that he had
claimed that mr hancock had said
in march that there was a plan to deal
with testing
in care homes and for the prime minister
to find out in april
that that hadn't been the case that
people hadn't been tested
before they were discharged and in terms
of the actual
detailed questioning um i think that mr
hancock
was kind of ducking specific allegations
and he kept just saying
that many of the allegations were
unsubstantiated
i should also say that jeremy hunt the
former health secretary former
leadership
contender and now the chair of the
health select committee also made the
point in the house that until there is
substantial
evidence to back up mr commons claims
that they are as it stands
unproven and i think what you saw in the
commons today was a
an attempt by conservative mps certainly
to rally round
and back the health secretary afterwards
what was an extremely
uncomfortable evidence session
for him from mr commons yesterday
what about the prime minister you know
do you get the sense that he does have
confidence in matt hancock
well it it was interesting in terms of
that uh pool clip
that interview with the prime minister
because a journalist did say to him do
you have full confidence
and he just carried on with his answer
about care homes now i should stress
that the government has said
that they have full confidence in matt
hancock but the prime minister didn't
actually explicitly answer that question
when he was asked it was almost like he
was in the moment
of answering another question on care
homes but in that
um in what he said i have the transcript
here in terms of what the prime minister
said
earlier uh he was asked about mr commons
telling the truth did mr cummings tell
the truth the prime minister said i'm
getting on
with delivering the road map that's his
dodge uh
you're not arguing uh with what mr
common said with the things he said and
the prime minister says
i make no comment on that he was also
asked whether tens of thousand people
died who didn't need to die
because of the prime minister's action
or inaction the prime minister said
i don't think so and then he also said
it had been an incredible difficult
series of decisions
he said i hope people do understand this
that when you go into lockdown it's a
very very
painful traumatic thing for people so he
didn't specifically go toe-to-toe
doesn't want to engage
directly with mr cummings he wants to
just not comment on it he wants to keep
the focus
on the vaccine program on his road map
he doesn't want to get drawn
into he said she said rouse but the fact
is that
boris johnson whatever you think of
dominic cummings whether you think he's
a credible witness or not
the prime minister put dominic cummings
at the heart of his operation
in number 10 for 18 months and whether
the prime minister likes it and or not
now that dominic cummings is very
publicly
turning on him his testimony cannot be
discounted
because the prime minister gave him that
power and put him
in the front and center stage of events